it is incredibly hard to do anything
this is a mistake
today we are gonna get our nails dude I
feel like my masculinity is pretty
secure there's not much anyone can say
or do that game like harm my esteem and
probably a little bit fragile so I think
this is actually gonna be a test for me
here are two pairs of gloves that you
may put on if you ever feel
uncomfortable or unsafe you never know
what happened in the public you never
know how dangerous people could be
especially towards people for just
wearing nails seems ridiculous to me but
it could happen so it's something to
watch out for so I'm happy to have these
let's go
get some nails done longer than I've
wanted to be a little bit longer than
that like I'm thinking like the Rihanna
that length seems fine to me I was so
happy about this I think it's gonna be
fun
Beyonce does it and if it's good enough
for her it's good enough for me
if you don't think you're being extra
with those on right now on that extra
it's the right amount you wouldn't let
them be this link for you me yeah
I'm more worried about like going out to
a bar or going out on the weekend to
like a club type setting where they're
like really macho masculine guys or
something that like are out there drunk
and ready to be mean I'm getting a
little bit nervous because it's getting
real right now I just got my nails done
a little bit more self-conscious about
it than I thought I think this will be
easy but the more I wear there the more
on my oh this is weird
honestly I'm not adjusting as well as I
thought I would but we'll see I've been
pretty nervous to show these to everyone
oh my god that's crazy
first of all they look like freaking
fabulous thank you
I do more feminine hand gestures is
really funny but I definitely feel his
evidence it took me ten minutes to get
my pants unbuttoned with these nails and
now I can't get them back up I'm
literally sitting here fumbling trying
to grab in earbud I really couldn't type
anything but the amount of that has
decreased my productivity this week is
literally my least favorite thing this
is really hard and I hate everything
about girls I want to break them up
right now I could did I am determined to
make it through this movie I know he
won't make it there believe he cried
last night about his pain I hope you
will make it there was a girl who
actually sort of saw my nails and just
sort of made this look like just like
really discussed it and maybe throwin
reacting negatively and it kind of like
made me question my masculinity like a
little bit all my life I definitely
noticed that there have been pressures
in terms of masculinity in that you want
to avoid things that might be feminine
so wearing nails for a week is something
that's definitely a little bit
uncomfortable today at the gym with my
nails I've been getting a couple of
strange looks it's just weird to be in a
place that's I guess hyper masculine and
have such a if I'm gonna consider the
object on my hands
I didn't feel weird until here and I'm
like I guess maybe I should've wore my
gloves because I'm gay when I was in
high school there were so many
insecurities that I had on top of being
a teenager I think I've just come to
terms with it I don't think about my
masculinity as
the rigid or having to be a certain way
I thought that I was gonna have a few
people who made me feel uncomfortable
today and it just didn't happen I think
it's just like a day-to-day experience
based on like who sees that this week
has helped me understand a lot more
about people it's a decorative thing and
I feel like anyone to be able to what
they want to do what a week it was a lot
harder than I thought when we started I
was like all about the nails I was like
yes this is gonna be fun live my best
life as you can see I broke one kind of
nervous to show people immediately got
positive sort of feedback and sort of
got more comfortable with it as the week
went on it definitely felt masculinity
issues at certain points of the week
there were definitely moments that I
felt weird about having nails and I just
think about it it literally doesn't make
sense to feel a type of way about these
because everyone has nails yes these are
a little bit more more ornate in there a
little bit more decorative but it's
literally just a way to express yourself
from this experience I think it's taught
me that where I once would have maybe
judged someone or like thought why would
they do that I no longer think it's a
big deal except I would sort of think
good on them for wearing those long
nails I bet you they can't type anymore
[Music]